[Musik]
sie zeige ich ihnen mal wenig anfangen
mitte genommen morgen auf der kommode
das content also ist das für mich vor
schluss vom training jetzt mit bussen
richtung mit guten vorsprung vor
juventus unbedingt zeigen zum zeigen wie
ihr anspruchsvolles training ist und
dann geht das
damit lässt ihnen ist wichtig und da
habe ich kombination von koordination
und denen seiner früher falls ich es
mein geschirr geführt als sie acht wird
ich hab mal weit nach dem picknick
gespürt ich höchstens noch drei wochen
bis honig kino bewege
laufen oder vielmehr davon laufen aus
lebensmaxime davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
bahn station coermühle bei zug
hier warte ich auf die zürcher alt
kantonsrätin liliane war die ehemalige
sp politikerin hat eine mission und ich
werde sie ein stück weit begleiten
liliane waldner ist vor rund 30 jahren
an multipler sklerose erkrankt ihre
selbst verordnete therapie laufen der
krankheit davonlaufen und zwar mit
system
seit gut drei jahren marschiert sie
praktisch täglich etappenweise dem
schweizer fluss netz entlang
[Musik]
kann das thema manchmal verfolgen und
das hilft mir und ich habe gemerkt die
flüsse fasziniert mich sollte ich mal
einfach für mich
die stadt marschieren ist das ist power
christliches dorf passiert mich und ich
laufe am fluss gegangen also gegen den
strom beruf also packte widerstand wurde
das ist einfach widerstand das ist was
ich machen werde
es geht da um widerstand zu überwinden
oder unterwegs abgestellt die schotten
und irgendwie ist eine normale strecke
und süße der weg zurück und das mit
resident erfolgt bis sie die liane
waldner zeigt mir ihr tägliches training
mit wandern gesunde ernährung und
übungen wie diesen auf die 64-jährige
den verlauf ihrer unheilbaren krankheit
positiv zu beeinflussen
multiple sklerose ist eine entzündliche
erkrankung des zentralen nervensystems
mit individuell unterschiedlichen
auswirkungen piercings vorraum sehr
stark im rückenmark beschädigt weniger
im im hirn bereich und das heißt hat es
für auswärtige
ja das haben verschiedene auswirkungen
machen den fck dass sich zwei mokka hat
sich optimal twitterer hohl und
natürlich bei mir skripal
gleichgewichtsstörungen taubheit die
schwere fahrerlaubnis lehmige bis in
roth studienautorinnen angeschnorrt wenn
sie wüssten dass hatte verlauf sie von
ihrer krankheit um mir der song sport
wissen sie ich tue mich eine
mietminderung nicht so beschäftigt war
selber dass ich jetzt immer gedanken
machen freundlicher mann klappen am
vorbeizogen
gekonnt war
mir die ex-politikerin aus reno irgendwo
noch bonds dieser stadt über das ende
spricht sie lieber über den anfang sehr
früh mit ja
[Gelächter]
die kleine liliane in der schweiz der
50er jahre eine attraktion ein
dunkelhäutiges außereheliches kind ohne
vater casino frage wo ich stände vor
warum man dann endlich in die schule
oder im kindergarten einem foto und dann
hat sie mir heute nicht erholt
in uganda und neue schotter und plante
einen filmstoff
man spürt es juliane walther ist stolz
auf ihre mutter die in jungen jahren
eine schauspielschule in england
besuchte dort lernte sie leigh annes
vater kennen einen afrikanischen
studenten dass die spanien froh dass sie
beide zusammenbleiben
sie hat eine 600er serie in afrika frau
und kongo hat und dass sie schaut den
afrikanischen markt so die hand halten
brauchen
und im nachhinein heraus gefunden dass
real und seine offizielle frau sind
nicht die einzigen
im späteren lebensgefährten ihrer mutter
von juliane walther einen ersatzvater
szenenwechsel juliane partner sie ist 36
und begeisterte werk lengerich
zusammen mit ihrer mutter und deren
freund verbringt sie ein paar ferientage
in ihrem lieblingsort kann das steht wir
schauen ein archiv beitrag des schweizer
fernsehens im film geht es um in der
schweiz lebende frauen mit afrikanischen
wurzeln
eine davon liliane wand hindurch
kindheit war der jungen frau
diskriminiert fühlt das nötig außen
vorteil empfunden
ich bin eh umsorgt wurde im mittelpunkt
so wie mich interessiert nicht ob sie
gut oder so das ist mir einfach muss
sage ich auch froh dass er bei uns sind
es hat mir irgendwie doch bestätigung
dass ich traue ihr vater habe ihr eine
eigentlich als diese aufnahmen
entstanden war multiple sklerose für
liane waldner noch kein thema es gab
zwar erste anzeichen doch die diagnose
fiel erst viel später
schwierig er gab das monopol brechen
schönleber kritik sie also im vorstand
geht also doch der ganze reihe
also man muss einfach ein dramolett hier
das als zone j j will ich gehöre zu der
generation
ich wollte nur dass hier um apollo
später steht sie wenn sie mal sehen auf
dem richtigen pfad der natur
[Musik]
wir gehen der lorze entlang einer von 40
schweizer füßen die liane waldner
bereits ab marschierte
insgesamt 2009 133 km die touren
dokumentiert sie auf ihrem fluss blog
[Musik]
wirklich und schlacht aber an ist jetzt
führt zoomen mit energie und ehrgeiz
treibt fluss projekt voran
ein ersatz die krankheit hatte ihren
gewohnten lebensfluss gestoppt
es ist natürlich schon so am anfang ist
es ein schock dass man so bis hat mit
hippie gehirn einmal unsere abruf liche
karriere verläuft macht dort zeigen
damals habe ich gedacht die karriere
gemacht meine kantonsrätin der stadt
sobald ich die position der bank den
verwaltungsräten
sie verwalten erpressung regierung sagt
nationalrat
liliane partner ist als rechte hand wird
zehn jahre arbeitete liane waldner für
die zürcher stadträtin emilie lieberherr
einer powerfrau die arbeit unter der
vorsteherin des sozialamtes war zeit und
kräftemäßig intensiv in das muss man
gesehen damit man die ganze aber noch
ein tor erzielt
die das einfach was oder bringen lassen
wo sie gegen alba in die karte position
war kann hätte tv rolle gespielt
überhaupt wegen positiver und negativer
sind fragen ob sie das ich besucht haben
und durch zig ist als bereit ist
engagiert ist ich hatte ja und weiter
über jahre hinweg andere positionen oder
die funktion der gewerkschaft in der
partei keine beobachter nicht gesehen
dass sie genau die fähigkeiten der
steigerung sehen dass ich sie für das
amt aus quark ich einen sehr
faszinierend ich möchte meinen traumjob
honig viele möglichkeiten einfluss auf
die damals aufkommenden symptome ihrer
krankheit hat sie anfänglich ignoriert
und später dann kassiert
sich aus einer getraut sagt wiesn-chefin
dich aber ich wollte den druck sie hat
immer gesagt du strotzt vor gesundheit
und verkauft und ich hatte einfach danke
ich glaub ich strotze vor gesundheit
oder ich konnte einfach sauber stück
will weil man dort den geschlechtern
vertragen ja das gebe zu ich jetzt so
weit die füße tragen ist bei mir am
meisten zu suchen
der weg der lotse entlang ist auch ein
industrie fahrt mit schautafeln sehr zur
freude von liliane waldner die gelernte
betriebsökonomie entpuppt sich als
technikfan macher lottermann sich hätte
um erbstücke mechanikerin oder elektrik
den lehrkörper mit der prius
kaufmännischen oder sorgen gesagt es ist
ja immerhin er hat der tat ich seit du
dann hast du es blau super quandt
das ist doch nicht normal für es für
frau wurde
ich hätte noch keine normen der prämie
bekanntlich sind sie in monza
was heißt immer und ich bin in normale
frau nominiert acht hat klassischen
abschätzige begriffe bei uns alles nicht
weit aber es ist sehr selbstbestimmt
emanzipierten frau ja das komme sagt
müssen sie die bürgerliche seite da man
immer dass ich jetzt eine ganze aber ich
meine irgendwann winziger freuen können
kritiker für das leben der wand entlang
und impressum einfach sicherheit in
sicherheit
ich gehe ja so genannte sturzgefährdet
operativ guten ruf ich begleite liliane
waldner an eine sp veranstaltung darf
ich 1000 meter platz da haben die sicht
für die zukunft gestaltet wird mir an
das frauenstimmrecht erkämpft der
bundesplatz mit relativ und ich haben
die zimmer nur die heimat eine
historische trillerpfeife kämpfen und
für gerechtigkeit entstehen das hat
willi waldner von kindesbeinen an
gelernt aufgewachsen mit mutter und
großmutter in einer
genossenschaftswohnung im kreis 4 dem
ehemaligen arbeiterviertel zürich doch
mich interessiert eigentlich weniger ihr
politisches denn ihr privatleben und
warum sie seit jahren solo ist im
internet von vornherein für den dienst
auch nein neid ausdrücklich weisen etwas
kunden der uno weitere frage eine
politische freunde geschickt
innenpolitischem ein wenig
die themen und der bibel
ich lasse sie davonlaufen nehme mir aber
vor an einem anderen tag noch einmal
nachzuhaken
dann kann ich es mir all the profs
gewissen dass ich eine der sendung wiso
kommen das letzte mal als ich weiss wie
gross wechselt das so schlimm wie es
dann wird es wieder heißen dass ich
üblich soziale stehen an der eingangstür
das aktuelle bundesratsfoto über dem
türrahmen ein krokodil
ein schal des fc kaiserslautern im
lehnstuhl nichts den eigenen finden sich
auch gegenstände ihrer verstorbenen
mutter in der wohnung
die beiden haben stets zusammen gewohnt
faszinierte drunk weit weg von die hse
ist und sie hat eine bedachte mich oft
welt zu bringen oder und das für das
binäre einfach dankbar roten ihr
leiblicher vater war zwar nicht da aber
trotzdem immer präsent
dort ruft auf dem bild mit mir das habe
ich geträumt dass ich für mich dauernd
ihre innere
lange zeit wusste sie nur seinen namen
sonst nichts dann im märz live ticker
nicht einmal tätig sehr schmal sind
klasse und zwar in st
idealen wurde im april 1979 von
ugandischen nationalen befreiungsfront
gestürzt
an der spitze jener die den ugandischen
diktator idi amin stürzten
liliane waldners vater josef jule
freiheitskämpfer und ehemaliger
universitätsrektor die tagesschau des
schweizer fernsehens sagte damals bilder
von der vereidigung von liliane waldners
vater zum ugandischen präsidenten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
doch es vergingen drei weitere jahre bis
milliarde waldner zu ihrem vater
kontaktaufnahmen dann brauche ich ihn
kennengelernt
am sechsten august 1982 und ich mein
vater mal gesehen und momentan ich muss
voll gar nichts weiter ruft wir diese
zweite geburt sie und ich erlebt habe
sich unterholz glücksfee und david rieff
london taxis der frau die hand aber frau
ist er mit begeisterung von der
geschicht dass da noch einiges größeres
kind in afrika ist und romanzen hat
jetzt die situation mit ihrem vater
ihres modebild prägten zu wählen in den
beziehungen egal ich habe post wie es
meiner mutter gegangen ist unter und das
halt immer noch unter sich und gott also
gleich erzählen wird dir vor ich habe
früher schon vorsichtig sie kann man
sich einfach plötzlich mit einem hemd
aus staub wie es passiert ist
davon laufen als lebensmaxime in bezug
auf die krankheit ist es ein aufbäumen
strotzen gegen den verlauf was die liebe
angeht ist ihr davonlaufen wohl eher
selbstschutz und flucht
[Musik]
ich bin immer dann legen wir nur am
schluss von der schippe kumpel müssen
sie waren erkennt ihr müsst mir der
ärmel richtige netze
das müssten typs i wo nachdem es hat
auch so manches kind mit mir um die von
den kunden kommt und jetzt sind die
flüchtet sich das straßenkind oder du
sie dokumentieren es sind ja sie können
sich ja irgendwie ihr kind oder aufgabe
suchen
das floß projekt die kabinen erkennen
würden
[Musik]